Muslim
said how can you answer to heaven so I
said God the propet, may
God bless him and grant him peace, may God’s
prayers and peace be upon him
Allah
eveny that
God is Glory be to Him
You can my sister think that if you do
n’t pray
you don’t observe the pillars just being
a good person like mother Teresa you got to
go to heaven like what is that you said to
pray
but she mother is going to go to heaven
because no she’s not what I to her
sheen
she hasn't believe in the true god you
tell her even many
there are many things came out about her
how she was abusing children yeah gen
I'm telling like you said she does notad
the last propet
just like the followers when Jesus came
to the people the people who reed Jesus
even if they follow prophet
gentle
women of the Moses argumentist
the problem today
but even men
we
even some men they are st men st but
women are different from men you know
woman a woman is known to be difficult
is
more ok
what  Shasha
to yes to be the cap of yes long time
beauti
westerned
[laughter]
come
this  question not me how toen believe in
God
Allah mercy the people
mercy
exclusive for those follow his prophet
and messengers so after prophet Muhammad upon him
for the chrans and the jewish and
every nation enter is they have to the
teach of the propet Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him,
missing priorities Allah
this the outcome of humanism which
focusing more on pleasing humans you
know when you centralize human being
your main focus to please human beings
but we to please human beings we are
here to the creator of everything
our central starting point is  Allah
we central Allah other people central
human beings will you go to heaven if
you don't practice the pillars noen
if you're a good person but you don't pray
you go to heaven
If
you are Muslim and you believe in Allah you do
not pray there is different opinions
among the scholar some schol said if you
die you punished you desire to be
punished butent you enter paradise but
some said you don't you are a
disbeliever for not praying because the
true manifestation
of the shadain
is in prayer before  anything go my
understanding is this when You die
youres and your minus your  good sins and
your bad sins.  Your good deed and your
bad so if your bad is
good how can you go to heaven?  Allah's
mercy.  Remember Allah can forgive and
show mercy.  I know but you have to go
you have to spend time and first and
then but remember deserves to be
punished.  Deserves to be punished but
again everything is up to Allah.
Allah
yes have so if a christian is a nice
person he the po he the po
difficult to the message is not what
they want to hear they off the go see my
point
gu see my they not even wearing hijab
for that's the first you my sister
SL
Abi Jahl
and merful to
African of course
because
But I'm try to tell them
tell them this western
and Michael Jackson up
Jor
God make Muslims like criminals How do you judge
telling them if you have been given  guidance
this is the pill serve them you don't
observe them a muslim Allah and I'm to
my neighbors and I'm to my dad I'm n to
my mom I go to heaven you the
commandment how can you go to heaven
that's a problem with this ideology of
many Muslims have been affected by which call
humanism ideology just
focus on people noting people this is a
nice person god is not fair because
going to hell that's not of your
business you just look after yourself no
god is fair because the crime
how are  you good long time you back
the biggest crime against Allah
associate partners with him  Because
associating partners with Allah, you are
causing yourself to be oppressed. You
become an oppressor. Why? What is oppression?
When you take someone's right and
give it to someone who doesn't deserve it, you
take Allah's
right and give it to a tree, a prophet, or a righteous person.
This is called oppression, and it's the
greatest
type of oppression. There are three types of oppression: when you oppress yourself, when you oppress
others, and when you
oppress Allah's right. The greatest oppression is when you oppress Allah's right by
taking His right
and giving it to someone else. Look at what's happening in Gaza. The judge still has his way. Of course, Allah is for them. Prophet Muhammad suffered. Prophet Jesus suffered. Prophets suffered. Say, "The more hardship you endure, the more God loves you." That's right. That's right. You. Allah is true. Glory be to
Allah. Glory be to Allah. How
many prayers? Glory be to Allah. The
Arabs say, "How many a
calamity contains a blessing."
Algeria.
Praise be to
Allah.
Praise be to Allah. Allah is
the Greatest.
True.
Ask our brothers and sisters in India
and
China.
Supplication. Supplication.
God willing.  Peace be upon you